welcome back to Pittsburgh Joshua
success was a math teacher at the turbo
School in Oxford that was until one
lesson in 2017 when he praised a group
of female students on their hard work or
one of the girls identifies as a
transgender boy and this week in the
first case of his kind in the UK Joshua
success was banned from every classroom
in England for not using the pupils
preferred pronouns Mr Stockton said he
apologized immediately and is being
persecuted because of his Christian
beliefs and he joins me now well thank
you for coming on Facebook when I sent
him thank you pierce to stop exactly
what happened
um well
it was the tra Hearing in recent months
and the principal reason that they
Banned Me from every classroom in the UK
as you mentioned was for refusing to use
the pronouns that a particular student
wanted to what did you actually say you
called the group girls yeah I was two
two girls at the front of the class and
one of them identified as a boy and I
agree with the policy exchange report
recently released by the government
where it says that you know we're
letting down a generation of young
people affirmingham in these
um you know dispositions
um you know in the UK you need a gender
recognition certificate and that is post
18 and so it really is a serious issue
and it's effective schools Across the
Nation and I mean we're seeing a lot of
kids now identifying something other
than their biological sex what do you
think of that phenomenon well I think
it's um really something our society
should be taking much more seriously you
know it's a path these students go down
a path of taking very strong drugs and
surgery and it's something that
shouldn't be so quickly brought into
classrooms across the country and it's
happening uh everywhere as you've seen
in the news reports not just for me but
for other teachers you called these two
students girls one of them was a
transgender Boy by her own or his own
definition whichever you want to say it
right this is a time this is you know
five six years ago when this issue
wasn't anyone who's prevalent as it is
now did you realize immediately this
might be a problem
uh I well I wasn't really um Savvy I
didn't know about the issue as we've
come to know about it and um you know
but at the time with my Christian
convictions I I thought an appropriate
stance to
um you know uh just use the student's
name and what happened to you
um well I mean the school sort of took a
case against me and it's ended out all
the way at the what were you accused of
doing accused of using the wrong
pronouns literally literally yeah
accused of using the wrong pronouns and
that was actually the principal reason
that the Department of Education used
against me
um that I refused to use the pronouns so
really quite a shocking and sad day for
myself personally but even for England
you know I mean the argument that was
put forward against you was that you
should treat all pupils of dignity and
respect and if they're identifying in a
different way then you should feel
mandated to do that well I think the
safeguarding of the people is Paramount
in this situation and if you affirm
these students in their gender identity
then that could lead them down a path
um that maybe the one day they will get
regret and you know maybe it's something
that we should think about
um you know leaving for adults to decide
rather than such young students I'm
going down this path see on on this I'm
kind of you know I'm kind of sympathetic
to to what you're saying about that
issue that the pronoun misgendering and
so on with so many kids now following
what I think in most cases is just a fad
why should people have to change their
language to accommodate what seems to be
just a fad the complication I think in
your case is that you have very strong
Christian beliefs or I would say beliefs
that pertain to your religion would you
accept that I accept that pierce yeah so
you have uh four Abominations on your
website for example yes
um abortion homosexuality porn and Islam
yes you call them Abominations yes is it
right well I mean when I read that I was
like hang on is it right that any
teacher
should be teaching kids if they call
those four things Abominations we
understand Pierce those things happened
outside of the classroom you know that's
my own personal I understand that yeah
understand that but in one case it was
cited that you had for example on the
issue of gay marriage you'd said to kids
in the class that it should be between a
man and woman yeah a student asked me
about my conviction and and that was
what I said that it should marriage
should be between a man and a woman but
um you know the Bible very clearly
describes many things as sinful and as
not good things for us and the Bible
also tells you to Stone people for
various offenses and we don't do that
anymore I mean the point is well we all
deserve I mean I'm a Catholic but I
wouldn't I wouldn't use language like
these are all Abominations particularly
when a lot of people in this country are
now gay obviously you think that that's
abominable yes um and that's fine that's
your it's your prerogative to have that
opinion but there will be people who
think well hang on this these are pretty
hardcore views of someone who wants to
teach young children I understand that
people might disagree with me Pierce but
I'm that's a pretty Orthodox Christian
view to think that these things are
sinful and not um good I don't know any
Christians who say Islam is an
abomination
well I know some but they're not it's
not Orthodox well that's not Orthodox
Christian teaching of course it's
standard Christian teaching you know to
not agree with Islam and you know to not
that it's an Abomination another
religion there's respect for Islam but I
respect Muslims very much peace but you
don't you call their religion an
Abomination you must separate ideas from
people people listen on your website you
say Islam is an Abomination that's not
respecting a religion well it's the
opposite of respecting a religion no I
disagree very much with Islam that's
fine it's entirely your prerogative I'm
just saying that if you want to be a
teacher is it compatible with being a
teacher to have a personal website which
lists a series of Abominations including
the right to be gay the right to have an
abortion legal pornography Islam another
massive religion one and a half billion
people it just seems to me if I was a if
I was a parent at that school and I read
that on your website I would be
concerned well I think it's up to
parents to look these things up if they
want to but all parents that I've um had
interactions with would say that I'm a
very respectable man and I'm always I
did the job at hand but I think in our
free Society I think that I'd be able to
share those things outside the classroom
you now go into the street and you you
talk just watch a little clip of what
you do
that there's one way
into heaven
his name is Jesus Christ
this is an urgent plea with your spirit
man I'm not just talking to your minds
I'm talking to your spirit to your heart
that you might be awoken from the death
of this generation
that you met might be shaken out of the
depths of darkness and into the Glorious
light of the kingdom of God
I mean again
I'm not sure I'd feel that comfortable
about having a teacher of my young kid
who's out there doing that every weekend
and you know it's pretty Orthodox
Christian beliefs that I'm it's fine but
your teacher out there and basically
ranting away on the street it doesn't it
wouldn't lend itself to most parents to
think that that is entirely compatible
with teaching kids well you'd have to
see me in the classroom Pierce I'm a
good practitioner when were you last in
a classroom if well three or four years
ago now you want to teach again I'd love
to teach it again I enjoy teaching my
dad's a teacher and I've what does your
dad make of all this he said he supports
me yeah
yeah disagree with all your views
um well he's a Christian himself Pierce
he was an artist he was an re teacher
for for um 30 years but does he agree
that all these things are Abominations
well appears this is Biblical teaching
it's not it shouldn't be a surprise to
you or anyone else well like I said the
Bible also teaches people to Stone
people to death but we don't do that
well that's the civilization that's the
penalty for sin Pierce but Jesus so for
adultery you would have died just to
clarify then for adultery you think is
right to Stone people to death I think
that as they do in Saudi Arabia for
example yeah all sin deserves the death
penalty and Jesus so adultery let me
finish please
it's an important point is adultery a
sin
Jesus died on the cross for Sinners he
took the place Joshua his adultery a sin
yes so you want to execute everyone is
doing an adultery all sin all 613 two
demons all sin is is punishable by death
right Joshua that's nuts mate and that's
what the Bible and that's the problem
you see peace you start off you have me
at the start you had me about the
pronoun issue because I think it's
incredibly complicated and I don't see I
also have a big concern about number of
kids who are basically putting their
hands up saying I'm a woman I'm a girl
I'm a boy with a knot and so on
um but this stuff is nuts mate if you're
going to say that everyone who's a
sinner by the rule of the Bible has to
be killed there's no one left only you
left and I don't feel comfortable about
the world
Joshua suck live a life don't be silly I
am the worst of Sinners peers why are
you still alive because Christ has died
for Sinners he took the place they were
by your yardstick you should be executed
yes I should be who buy God he's the
judge of all but you're gonna I'm gonna
go and submit yourself for execution no
but Jesus is it's called penal
substitution huh it's called it's a it's
a theological
when you talk that way it disqualifies
you in my eyes from being a teacher not
the pronoun stuff I'm that I'm with you
on this stuff it's nuts we should be in
a free Society totally and you're by the
way allowed up as many nutty views as
you like I just don't think Nazi in your
opinion I think your opinion in 99 of
the entire planet your views are nothing
your world maybe but no people don't
think that everyone who commits adultery
should be executed tomorrow no uh this
is what the Bible teaches greed gluttony
all those things so anyone's greedy gets
executed anyone who's gluttonous gets
executed have too many donuts Joshua
says you wheeled off to the this is what
the Bible teaches to be put to death and
this and this isn't really being taught
in our generation no there's a reason
it's not taught in our generation but
Christ is a completely sacrifice for sin
yes I know Jesus Christ did sacrifice
himself but you don't think Jesus Christ
will be sitting here today at my desk
saying every single person who commits
an act of greed or gluttony or adultery
should be summarily executed if you do
things you do think that you have a very
warped idea well actually the Bible is
supposed to mean no I think what's
happened is you've got your own view of
what the Bible says but you haven't
really ever been told what the Bible
says I've read the Bible I was actually
given spiritual guidance by Catholic
nuns when I was 11 years old uh for a
couple of years I'm very very sad with
the Bible but honestly when I hear
people say that for all these sins
you've got to be put to death it's nuts
so for that you shouldn't be teaching
well Christ has taken our place Pierce
and I think I should be well
unfortunately uh someone from YMCA is
about to take your place uh on the show
I'm afraid and that's it but good to see
you thank you Joshua